mais le bouteilles remplies puis
empaquez toutes les minutes
l'automatisation règne en maître dans la
nouvelle brasserie de motion course à
Longueuil construite au cou de 525
millions de dollars pour la petite
histoire c'est aussi le plus gros
investissement comment le son de course
a fait dans l'histoire récentes de
l'entreprise au monde
d'ici sorte 230 millions de litres de
bière par année destiné presque
exclusivement au marché québécois tout
le génie réside dans ce système
d'entreposage automatisés 22000 palettes
sont répartis sur 8 étages
l'automatisation a toutefois un prix
l'entreprise passe de plus de 500
employés à 420 travailleurs sur le front
environnemental réunir le brassage et
l'anthroposage sous un même toit permet
de réduire le transport de marchandises
ici à Longueuil on parle de 40% de moins
que notre de la rue Notre-Dame fini les
chambres froides on les remplace par des
cuves frigorifiques beaucoup moins
énergivores la magie de la fermentation
s'opère sous nos yeux les recettes
originales brassées dans de l'équipement
dernier cri offre le même goût d'antan
ou presque on est en mesure de sortir
plus de petits petits améliorations un
peu plus de fruits Donald Trump
mais la soif croissante des
consommateurs pour la bière en canette
ternit le bilan environnemental du
brasseur bicentenaire l'emballage en
aluminium moins écologique que les
bouteilles réutilisables atteint
maintenant 70% des ventes donc si le
consommateur effectivement comme on l'a
vu au fil des dernières années demande
plus de canettes à nous de voir comment
la production de ces canettes peut se
faire plus de façon plus efficace
l'usine d'un million de pieds carrés
repose sur un terrain qui fait 6 fois sa
superficie ce qui permettra à mousse une
course d'augmenter la taille de ses
installations et de sa production au
rythme de la demande ici Jean-Philippe
Radio-Canada Longueuil